president biden needs to start me up
he's desperately seeking a major reset
after making the republicans look great
again support for the gop is booming to
levels not seen since 1995 26 years
gallup showing a dramatic political
shift after just one year of president
biden 47 percent of americans now
calling themselves republicans while
only 42 percent claim to be democrats
47-42
the white house frantically looking to
right their ship after seeing these
disastrous numbers plotting a new
communications strategy for the
president one that connects to all
americans they say and don't you dare
blame the president for his failures
watch guests on cnn looking to shift the
blame
he got infrastructure passed and that's
a good thing because success can can
breed success he is putting the full
force the presidency behind i think the
problem for the democrats right now is
is not that they have bad leaders
they're bad followers
bad followers you kidding me we thought
the pandemic was over that's what it's
about isn't it isn't this disastrous
approval greg all are mostly about kovid
the failure to stop kovid i think so
because i mean
right now the the democrats can only
drive in two gears symbolic rhetoric and
race shaming so their their muscles of
atrophied and they can't really battle
to fight the supply chain problems or
the border or crime or inflation or
covid because they're just better at
virtue signaling and getting great
responses from twitter the most amazing
truth about this if you want to be more
popular in america be the party out of
power remember the party uh in power the
democrats used to be out of power and
they could strut and they could
pontificate and they could rage but now
they're in power and they have to work
and now we're seeing that they're
absolutely hopeless but what if the
republicans get more done now because
the democrats are failing a 14-point
surge is pretty amazing you're going to
get more congressional seats more senate
seats maybe more governors and you see
these progressive policies being exposed
so i think you should enjoy being out of
power because those in power fail and
you benefit and the dynamic goes both
ways it'll happen to the republicans
beauty of the system president biden is
he's clearly fail failing on a covet and
the other items that greg mentioned
there kennedy uh but he seems easily
distracted he seems disconnected he
jumps from buildback better to voting
rights to who who knows what's next uh
you know who's to blame is it him is his
staff the white house chief of staff ron
clean
rasputin should he be fired what do you
think
yeah i think you should fire them all
and the only good thing about this is
for those of us who saw this coming and
have seen socialism take root and
destroy other countries from north korea
to venezuela i'm just happy to see that
american voters are snapping to their
senses
faster
that's the good news because they're not
going to stand up for a lot of it
geraldo it's not just
it's not just kovid because they have
been lied to on pretty much every level
it's also inflation and not being able
to afford things and having to make
sacrifices deciding where you're going
to spend what little money you have
because inflation as you know is
outpacing wage growth and they can't
fall back on well you know wages are
rising well they're not necessarily when
gas and meat cost twice what they did a
year ago this administration has to stop
lying about things they have to stop
blaming everyone else for these problems
which is what paul begala just did and
they have to stop propagandizing which
is what gen saki does every single day
be honest with people let them know
you're in a crisis let them know it's
difficult tell them what you're going to
do and then go ahead and do it and stop
blaming the guy who's getting shorted
for the problems that you've created
and yet jesse paul begala did exactly
what kennedy just said
it's not bad leaders it's bad followers
uh they're trying to shift
responsibility given the catastrophe for
these poll numbers eh
guys like magala they get lucky they
latch on to a talented politician he
takes them all the way to the top and
then everybody thinks begal is some
wizard and they pay him a bunch of
consulting fees for the rest of his
stupid life but if you listen to what he
says when he opens his mouth he doesn't
make any sense this guy's not
responsible for any politician success
he just got lucky just was on the right
place at the right time everybody knows
what that's about geraldo
the country is tired of struggling we
have sat
we have sacrificed a lot and it's been a
very turbulent last couple years at this
point we want schools open we want to go
into a subway without getting pushed to
our death we don't want to be stranded
in the airport for 17 hours because of a
covid mandate we don't want to fill up
the gas tank and have it cost 20 more
dollars than it did last year those are
just simple things that the country
wants we don't want to be inconvenienced
anymore we just want a smooth life and
we want to earn a nice living
and joe biden has somehow taken his eye
off that ball and is banging his head
against the wall talking about election
reform or electric cars or things the
country's not even thinking about and
all we're over here saying joe
over here
pay attention to us this is what we care
about and he doesn't look and that's why
the country's so angry right now it's
like the guy's he's just not paying
attention
and emily what they're doing is
demonizing senators mansion in cinema
you think that's going to bring those
two democratic senators into line to
vote with uh with their party well one
of the hallmarks of the democratic party
is that they blame absolutely everyone
else but themselves whoever has the
microphone is blaming someone else and
the whole bad followers versus bad
leaders is an example and again another
example is blaming cinema and mansion
but it doesn't matter because the end of
the day this administration blames you
we're blamed regular average americans
right the real terrorists in the
neighborhood is the one that flies the
american flag right the real proponents
behind this horrible pandemic are the
unvaccinated whatever it is it's not
them it's us and i think the numbers
that should that biden should pay
attention to coming out of those reports
are these two number one the smallest
slimmest minority in this country are
the actual liberals and yet we see he
continues to capitulate to them he
continues to think that those are the
voices that his policy needs to reflect
and the second data point is that 57 of
independents disapprove of his
leadership and of his administration and
it is those votes that he needs to be
calling right now and those are the
moderates those are the ones in the
middle the reasonable normal people and
final point i just find it ironic that
in his reset plan it's going to be about
engaging more quote communicating
directly with americans but as of this
point we have not identified how to do
that yet how about just being honest bro
just pick up a microphone and be normal
for once i won't hold my breath well
that'll be a fun it'll be a fun press
conference tomorrow hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else